BECOMING AND WE OUGHT TO
FIGHT THAT ROGER STONE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
HE HAS BEEN IN THE NEWS ALL
DAY AUTHOR OF NEW BOOK
CALLED THE MYTH OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
ROGER STONE, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
I'M A LITTLE TIRED BUT I'M
GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> Tucker: SO, JUST TO GET
THE MECHANICS OF WHAT
HAPPENED THIS MORNING OUT OF
THE WAY, WE HAVE SEEN THE
TAPES BY CNN REMARKABLY
ACROSS THE STREET FROM YOUR
HOUSE VERY EARLY THIS
MORNING.
AND WE SAW THE VERY LARGE
NUMBER OF ARMED FEDERAL
AGENTS BRINGING YOU OUT OF
THE HOUSE.
IS THERE SOMETHING WE DON'T
KNOW?
DO YOU HAVE AN ARSENAL AT
HOME?
HAD YOU MADE THREATS AGAINST
PROSECUTORS SUCH AS
VIOLENCE?
IS THERE CONTEXT WE DON'T
HAVE?
>> NO.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S
DISCONCERTING THAT CNN WAS
AWARE THAT I WOULD BE
ARRESTED BEFORE MY LAWYERS
WERE INFORMED.
THAT'S DISTURBING.
IF IT WAS A DANGEROUS
SITUATION, WHICH WOULD MERIT
THE SWAT TEAM, WELL THEN,
CNN'S CAMERA MEN WOULD BE IN
DANGER.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO BE THERE.
I HAD NO FIREARM IN THE
HOUSE.
I DON'T HAVE A PERMIT FOR A
FIREARM.
I DON'T OWN A FIREARM.
ONLY MY WIFE, MY TWO DOGS
AND MY THREE CATS WERE AT
HOME.
I'M NOT A FLIGHT RISK.
IN FACT, I THINK MY PASSPORT
HAS EXPIRED OR IT WILL
EXPIRE IN A FEW DAYS.
I HAVE NO RECORD OF CRIMINAL
PAST.
AND, FRANKLY, THEY JUST
COULD HAVE CONTACTED MY
ATTORNEY AND I WOULD HAVE
VOLUNTARILY TURNED MYSELF.
IN THE PROOF OF THIS IS THAT
ONLY HOURS LATER THE JUDGE
GRANTED ME A $250,000 SURETY
BOND, MEANING ON MY
SIGNATURE WITH NO FUNDS PUT
FORTH BECAUSE I'M NOT A
FLIGHT RISK.
AND AS FAR AS THE
GOVERNMENT'S CONTENTION THAT
THEY WERE CONCERNED THAT I
WOULD DESTROY EVIDENCE, THEY
HAVE BEEN IN MY EMAIL AND MY
TEXT MESSAGES AND MY PHONE
CALLS FOR TWO YEARS.
PROBABLY LONGER BECAUSE THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED ON
JANUARY 20TH, '17 THAT I WAS
AMONG THREE PEOPLE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN UNDER ACTIVE
SURVEILLANCE.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT IN
DISCOVERY OF THIS CASE.
>> Tucker: THAT GETS RIGHT
TO THE HEART OF THE CHARGES
AGAINST YOU WHICH ARE
PRIMARILY FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU ARE
ACCUSED OF LYING TO CONGRESS
ABOUT IS WHETHER OR NOT
THERE WAS ANY EVIDENCE YOU
HAD EVIDENCE OF
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN YOU
AND INTERMEDIARY IN JULIAN
ASSANGE.
DID YOU LIE ABOUT THAT?
AGAIN, GIVEN THAT YOU KNEW
THEY HAD YOUR ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS AND WOULD
KNOW THE ANSWER ALREADY,
WOULDN'T THAT BE A STUPID
THING TO LIE ABOUT?
WHAT IS THIS CHARGE ABOUT?
>> YES, INDEED.
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
DID I FORGET THAT I HAD TEXT
MESSAGES FROM AN OLD CELL
PHONE THAT WERE ENTIRELY
EXCULPATORY WHICH PROVED
EVERYTHING I HAD SAID ABOUT
CREDICO BEING MY SOURCE
REGARDING THE SIGNIFICANCE
AND THE OCTOBER RELEASE DATE
OF THE WIKILEAKS MATERIAL
WAS ACCURATE.
I BELIEVE HE LIED TO THE
GRAND JURY ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S BEEN REPORTED.
BUT HE APPEARS NOT TO BE
BEING PROSECUTED FOR
PERJURY.
BUT, I FORGOT EXCULPATORY
INFORMATION AND, THEREFORE,
I WILL.
IF ANYBODY HAD BOTHERED TO
READ MY WEBSITE, THE STONE
COLD TRUTH, THEY WOULD KNOW
THAT I BASICALLY REFUTED AND
DOCUMENTED THE REPUTATION OF
VIRTUALLY EVERY CHARGE IN
THIS INDICTMENT.
THE INDICTMENT IS THIN,
INDEED.
SO WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
IT'S ABOUT SILENCING ME.
THERE IS A WAR ON
ALTERNATIVE MEDIA.
THERE IS A WAR WHERE THEY
ARE TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE
POLITICAL EXPRESSION.
THERE IS A WAR WHERE THEY
ARE TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE
FREE SPEECH.
THE EFFORTS TO SHUT DOWN MY
SHOW AT INFO WARS, THE
EFFORTS TO SEE YOU LENS ALEX
JONES WHO IS ONE OF MY
GREATEST SUPPORTERS AND
PROPONENTS ARE PART OF THIS
WAR.
SO, I INTEND TO PLEAD NOT
GUILTY.
I BELIEVE I WILL BE
VINDICATED.
IT'S FUNNY TO WATCH BAHARA
ON CNN SAY THIS IS A SLAM
DUNK, CALLS ME A LIAR.
HERE IS A GUY WHO A JUDGE
LASHED FOR LYING IN THE
WILLIAM WALTON CASE.
YOU ARE THE LIAR, PREET.
WATCHING THE LAWYERS JUMP TO
CONCLUSIONS, TUCKER SAYING
OH, WELL, THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIAL WHO DIRECTED STONE
TO FIND OUT ABOUT WIKILEAKS
WAS DONALD TRUMP.
NO, IT WAS NOT.
THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS IN
HERE IN THE INDICTMENT THAT
ARE SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: WHO WAS IT IF IT
WASN'T THE PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, I HAVE TO SPECULATE
ABOUT THAT.
SINCE IT NEVER HAPPENED, IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT THEY HAVE
COMPOSED TESTIMONY FOR
SOMEONE.
PERHAPS RICK GATES, PERHAPS
STEVE BANNON.
PERHAPS SOMEONE IS BEARING
FALSE WITNESS AGAINST ME.
BUT, KNOWING WHAT'S IN MY
EMAIL, AND MY TEXT MESSAGES,
THERE IS NO CORROBORATION
WHATSOEVER FOR THIS.
AND AS FOR MY EMAIL EXCHANGE
WITH STEVE BANNON,
EVERYTHING I TOLD HIM IN THE
EXCHANGE WAS PUBLICLY
REPORTED INFORMATION.
POLITICAL REPORT IS THAT
AFTER ASSANGE ANNOUNCED ON
OCTOBER 1st THAT HE HAD
NOTHING THAT DAY BUT WOULD
HAVE RELEASES EVERY WEEK FOR
THE NEXT 10 WEEKS AND THAT
ALL INFORMATION ON THE
ELECTION PERTAINING TO THE
ELECTION WOULD BE RELEASED
IN THE WEEKS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
THAT WAS PUBLIC INFORMATION.
AND IT HAD ALSO BEEN
REPORTED THAT ASSANGE HAD
SECURITY CONCERNS THAT DAY.
SO THE TWO THINGS I TOLD
BANNON WERE PUBLIC
INFORMATION, NOT THE
SLIGHTEST BIT CONTROVERSIAL.
AS FOR THE CLAIM THAT --
>> Tucker: WHEN AND HOW DID
YOU LEARN THAT WIKILEAKS HAD
THESE STOLEN EMAILS?
>> WHEN JULIAN ASSANGE SAID
IT ON CNN ON JULY 22ND,
2016, AND THEN REPEATED IT
ON FOX ON AUGUST 24TH THIS
WAS NOT A STATE SECRET.
RANDY CREDICO WAS THE SOURCE
WHO TOLD ME THE MATERIAL WAS
INSIGNIFICANT, DYNAMITE, A
BOMBSHELL AND SO ON AND THAT
IT WOULD BE RELEASED IN
OCTOBER.
THERE IS ALSO, I THINK, A
REFERENCE TO DR. CORSI IN
HERE.
DR. JEROME CORSI NO TOLD ME
IN AN INTERVIEW WHEN HE WAS
IN AN INTERVIEW AUGUST 2ND
THAT THE WIKILEAKS
DISCLOSURE WOULD COME
THEREAFTER AND ONE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT IN
AUGUST THAT ALL TURNED OUT
TO BE INCORRECT.
SO THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
I RECEIVED ANYTHING
WHATSOEVER FROM WIKILEAKS,
THAT I KNEW THE SUBJECT OR
THE CONTENT OF THIS
MATERIAL.
THIS IS BEING USED TO
SILENCE ME.
>> Tucker: THAT ALLEGATION
IS NOT EVEN IN HERE.
THE ALLEGATION AS FAR AS I
CAN TELL FROM READING IT IS
THAT YOU LIED TO THIS
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE.
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THIS?
>> I HAVE NOT.
BUT, AGAIN, IF YOU WATCH CNN
OR MSNBC, YOU WOULDN'T KNOW
THAT BECAUSE THEY ACT AS
IF -- STONE ACTED AS THE
CONDUIT BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND WIKILEAKS OR
BETWEEN DONALD TRUMP AND
WIKILEAKS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT ANSWERED
THE WRITTEN INTERROGATORIES,
HE CORRECTLY AND HONESTLY
SAID ROGER STONE AND I NEVER
DISCUSSED THIS AND WE NEVER
DID.
>> Tucker: IT'S CLEAR, I
MEAN IT'S CLEAR FROM READING
THE INDICTMENT AND YOU HAVE
BEEN SAYING IT FOR AT LEAST
A YEAR, THAT THE FEDS WERE
SPYING ON YOUR TEXTS.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
I AGREE.
BASED ON THE INDICTMENT THAT
THEY RELEASED TODAY.
SO, GIVEN THAT THEY ARE
READING ALL OF YOUR TEXTS,
YOU TEXT WITH A HUGE, I
HAPPEN TO KNOW A HUGE NUMBER
OF JOURNALISTS, INCLUDING
ME, AND SOME OF THEM WORK
FOR CNN.
EVEN, MAYBE.
ALL OF THOSE TEXTS WERE
BEING READ BY A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THOSE
JOURNALISTS SOME OF WHOM ARE
TALKING ABOUT THIS CASE
RIGHT NOW ON TV THINK OF
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE
AMAZING THING IS THE PRESS
IS NOT COMING OUT AND
STANDING UP AGAINST THIS WAR
AGAINST FREE EXPRESSION.
THIS WAR AGAINST THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, WHICH IS REALLY A
WAR AGAINST THE PRESS.
LOOK, TUCKER, I THINK WE
BOTH KNOW THE GAME HERE.
WEAR STONE DOWN FINANCIALLY,
MAKE SURE HE IS BROKE SO HE
HAS TO PLEAD GUILTY TO THESE
CHARGES, EVEN THOUGH HE
DIDN'T COMMIT THEM.
AND THEN TRY TO FLIP ME
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
I'M FACING $2 MILLION NOW IN
POTENTIAL LEGAL FEES.
PEOPLE CAN GO TO STONE
DEFENSE FUND.COM TO HELP ME.
STONE DEFENSE FUND.COM.
I'M IN FOR THE FIGHT OF MY
LIFE.
I WILL NOT QUIT.
I WILL NOT FOLD.
I WILL NOT BEND.
I WILL NOT BEAR FALSE
WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I INTEND TO FIGHT BECAUSE
THIS INDICTMENT IS
FABRICATED.
THIS INDICTMENT IS THIN AS
CAN BE.
MY ATTORNEYS ARE HIGHLY
CONFIDENT THAT THEY CAN WIN
AN ACQUITTAL.
IF I CAN GET A FAIR TRIAL IN
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES YOU
FACE?
WHAT ARE YOUR LAWYERS
TELLING YOU THEY WILL PUSH
FOR IN TERMS OF THE
SENTENCE?
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY.
THEY HAVE NOT YET HAD
DISCUSSION.
THE ONLY OTHER THING I DO
WANT TO SAY IS THE FBI
AGENTS THIS MORNING WERE
EXTRAORDINARILY COURTEOUS
AFTER THE INITIAL
CONFRONTATION IN WHICH I WAS
HANDCUFFED BUT I WAS THEN
TAKEN TO THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE WHERE I WAS
SHACKLED, HAND AND FOOT AND
WENT THROUGH -- HAD TO SIT
IN THE HOLDING CELL BEFORE
THE JUDGE.
THE JUDGE WAS EMINENTLY FAIR
ISSUING BOND I'M RESTRICTED
IN MY TRAVEL.
CAN I ONLY TRAVEL TO THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA, NEW
YORK CITY AND SOUTHERN
FLORIDA I'M NOT A FLIGHT
RISK.
I'M 66 YEARS OLD AND I'M
ESSENTIALLY BROKE SINCE THE
LEAKS FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE DRIED UP
MY CONSULTING BUSINESS SINCE
THE CENSORSHIP AND SHADOW
BANNING ON FACEBOOK HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY DRIED UP MY
BOOK SALES.
AS YOU KNOW I HAD TO END MY
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE IN
DECEMBER BECAUSE I COULDN'T
MEET THE PREMIUMS ANYMORE.
EVERY DOLLAR I SCRAPE UP HAS
TO GO TO THIS FIGHT BUT,
STILL I FIGHT ON DO YOU
NOTICE A HERMINE HERE
EVERYONE GRIND UP IN THIS
INVESTIGATION DOESN'T HAVE
THE FUNDS TO FIGHT BACK.
PODESTA HASN'T BEEN.
IT'S YOU WHO CAN'T AFFORD
HEALTH INSURANCE.
PAPADOPOULOS WHO SEEMS
BROKE, CARTER PAGE.
WHO DO YOU EXPECT THE
3R50UR9 WILL INDICT NEXT IF
ANYONE.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
THEY SEEM TO BE IN HOT
PURSUIT OF DR. JERRY CORSI.
DR. CORSI SAID A NUMBER OF
THINGS ABOUT ME THAT ARE NOT
TRUE BUT HE SAYS HE WON'T
TESTIFY AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE THE EMAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES AND METADATA TO
PROVE MANY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS HE HAS MADE
AGAINST ME ARE NOT TRUE.
BUT HE CLEARLY HAS REFERRED
TO BLINDLY, OF COURSE, FROM
THIS INDICTMENT.
TAKE THREE STEPS BACK.
WHO CARES?
NO OFFENSE TO JEROME CORSI.
HE SEEMS LIKE A NICE GUY.
DOES ANYONE IN AMERICA
BELIEVE THAT JEROME CORSI IS
A THREAT TO AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY OUR WAY OF
LIFE OR DEMOCRACY.
IS HE?
THAT SEEMS CRAZY.
>> I DON'T THINK SO NOR I DO
THINK THAT POLITICAL OR
JOURNALISTIC INQUIRY
REGARDING WHAT THE TOPIC OF
THE WEEKS DISCLOSURE IS
SHOULD BE CRIMINALIZED.
I NEVER RECEIVED ANY
MATERIAL AROUND NO I NEVER
KNEW THAT JOHN PODESTA'S
EMAILS HAD BEEN STOLEN IN
ADVANCE AND MY TWEET IS NOT
IN REFERENCE TO THAT AND
RESEARCH MEMO THAT JERRY
CORSI WROTE ME REGARDING
OP-ED'S
PO-ED'S
PODED'S
PODESTS
PODESTA'S EXCLUSIVE DEAL IN
RUSSIA IS NOT PART OF A
COVERUP BECAUSE NO COVERUP
WAS REQUIRED.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU WATCH
THE CLIP THAT WE PLAYED I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD THE
CHANCE TO WATCH THE
KARAGEORGE OF YOU ON
TELEVISION TODAY OR SEE ON
THE INTERNET PEOPLE CHEER
FOR YOU TO GET RAPED IN
PRISON OR PEOPLE CELEBRATING
YOUR INDICTMENT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
>> WELL, I MUST TELL YOU,
WE'RE IN A VERY BAD PLACE IN
TERMS OF OUR POLITICS.
I GET FOUR OR FIVE DEATH
THREATS A WEEK.
I CAN'T GO OUT TO A PUBLIC
RESTAURANT OR AIRPORT OR
TRAVEL BY MYSELF NOW BECAUSE
PEOPLE WANT TO MIX IT UP.
THEY DON'T WANT TO JUST YELL
AT YOU.
SOME OF THEM WANT TO TAKE A
SWING AT YOU.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T FEEL THAT
WAY ABOUT THEM I DISAGREE
WITH THEM I'M NOT FOR
VIOLENCE.
I DON'T THINK VIOLENCE
SOLVES ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> NOW I NEED SECURITY FOR
MY FAMILY, FOR MYSELF AND
THAT COSTS MONEY.
WHICH IS WHY I HAVE ASKED
THE PUBLIC FOR HELP.